Hey you, are you wasting your time on
social media again? Your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a message, a Dawah center.
Establishing a message to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So, that makes the reward
even greater. So, give generously and
Allah Azza wa Jal will give you even
more.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. How are you guys doing?
Alhamdulillah, I'm doing good, bro.
>> You're doing all right, yeah?
Alhamdulillah rabbil alamin. You're all
right? Yeah, alhamdulillah.
>> with you? Anything new?
Nah, nah, alhamdulillah. That's about
it. That's about
>> [laughter]
>> We're back, uh, the comedic duo, the
champ,
the most electrifying man in all of, uh,
the Dawah. You went from duo to man.
No, I'm talking about myself. Okay.
>> as well, isn't it? Okay. So, why did you
start with duo then? Well, we were
talking about that and then, you know, I
moved on to greater things. That was a
flop still.
>> Some more important things.
Some more important [laughter] things.
Well, talking about, uh, a duo that came
together, which was kind of unexpected,
is, uh, Tucker Carlson and Piers Morgan,
a person who I've interacted with
multiple times. With Tucker Carlson? No,
I've never actually interacted with him.
Maybe Tucker Carlson wants to engage
with the Muslim community. He's been
speaking about them. Come on, Tucker.
Plus, he's in the UK as well, so might
as well, innit? Let's make Let's make it
happen. We might as well. Uh, come. We
We We like what you've been saying
recently about, uh, Israel and
Palestine. We like the fact that you've
taken the, uh, the courageous and
gallant stance. And we also like what
you said recently. Let's take a little
look and listen, yeah? Mhm. Look and
listen. Okay. Let's do what he said, uh,
him and and Piers, and come back and
respond in kind. Yeah, the Muslim
problem has been massively overstated.
>> an op, obviously.
>> Yeah. Hate the Muslims. No, I I don't We
don't know where that's coming from. I
don't like I I hate it. In my high
street alone, in West London, most of
the businesses would have Muslim
employees there or people who are not
>> how is hate the Muslims better than hate
the Christians or hate the Jews?
>> No, it's all the same. It's not. It's
the same. And I heard you I heard you
say that This is the point I come from.
Hatred is hatred is hatred.
>> agree.
>> matter who you're hating. The moment
you're in the hate game, then I think
you're losing whatever argument is
you're trying to have.
>> I totally agree. And but moving off from
hate and getting back to the world I
live in, which is fear and distrust and
gut-level loathing,
>> Yeah. it's the secular people who are
the problem. I've never had an argument
with a Muslim with an actual Muslim. I'm
from Bangladesh. I'm a Muslim. We'd
probably agree on a lot.
So, what do you think of that, Aziza?
So, there was,
uh, a good few points there.
>> Yeah. I think both of them were very
balanced.
>> Yes. Saying that the Muslim problem is
overstated. Um, uh, in fact, Georgia
State University, he says that Muslims
get, especially Muslim terrorists, get 4
and 1/2 times more coverage than a
terrorist of any other faith.
>> Yeah. Then when you look at Muslims that
have done well, Mhm.
>> Yeah, well in terms of being heroic,
having a heroic kind of action or a
stance. Yeah.
>> Recently, we heard of Hamza Abbar, who
was a Saudi, about 22-year-old student,
who saw a white girl being raped. He
went, not only chased the guy away, but
then pursued him, restrained him until
the police came. There was no mention of
his religion, of his ethnicity in the
headlines. You had to dig deep, and
there it was buried somewhere. Either
had to be inferred, or I mean, his
ethnicity was there underneath the
picture. You had Abdullah, yeah, which
is literally translated as a slave of
Allah.
>> Yeah. Leicester Square, he saw a woman
Yeah. and a child, a little girl get
stabbed. He jumped on the guy and
>> Yes, I remember that one, yeah. And then
he saved them.
>> Yeah, it's underreported, this stuff,
isn't it?
>> Well, it really wasn't. Third thing,
recent stabbing on the train. A guy
called Samir was actually stabbed. Yes,
the Algerian guy was stabbed, uh, saving
the lives of countless people. No
mention of his religion. No mention of
>> Even his ethnicity, even.
>> his ethnicity or which verse of the
Quran did he get that from?
>> [laughter]
>> You know what I mean?
There's absolutely no mention of
>> a good point. So, one thing gets
understated, one thing gets overstated.
And obviously, in the debate that I had
with,
uh, with Destiny in Oxford Union, which
by the way, the Oxford Union haven't put
up yet, which I'm now wondering why, cuz
they said they would, uh, as, you know,
uh, Destiny hasn't spoken about himself
at all after the four obvious reasons,
but Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Putting that to the side, but the Oxford
Union haven't put it up, and they've put
very unsavory characters on there.
They've
>> Tommy Robinson was there.
>> Tommy Robinson. But they also had that
guy, Musab, by the way. Musab, I think I
forget his full name.
>> The Israeli simp. Yeah, and he was
saying all kinds of, like, you know,
provocative things and stuff in there.
But the point is, putting that aside,
the point The arguments I was making,
uh, in the
in the immigration segment of that
debate was, number one, that Muslims
account for a disproportionately large
number
of people as medical staff in the NHS,
all right? So, they're 6% Muslim
population, but they represent 22% of
medical staff in the NHS. That's a
grossly overrepresented, actually,
uh, figure. And obviously, something
which is not mentioned by, uh, the
media, uh, something which many of these
right-wing, far-right pundits never uh,
speak about. The fact that Muslims,
according to charity UK, uh, Christie,
sorry, charity UK,
they also say that, um,
Muslims are four times more likely to
give charity than their non-Muslim
counterpart.
Uh, and I also made the point that So,
you've got the charity aspect, you've
got the NHS aspect, okay? So, they're
the greatest helpers, uh, and then the
greatest,
um, charity givers. But also,
you have, uh, the point about the
economy. Okay? That Muslims account for
about 70 billion of the UK economy,
which is a very, very significant
amount. It's the same output as, uh,
Birmingham and Manchester combined. And
that really, if you were to remove this,
cuz these people that talk about
removing it, it would collapse the
economy. Like, let alone removing all
the minorities in England or UK. It
would actually collapse the the economy.
Britain would actually become a, quote
unquote, developing country. Like, if
that was Cuz a lot of these people don't
think about it, right? If you removed
that much injection out of the economy,
it would cause an economic crash the
like of which we've never seen before in
British history, you know? So, these
things are never thought about.
>> I would even say even with regards to
the integration of the Muslims in the UK
as well. There was a 2015 poll that was
done, in which a whopping 95%
of Muslims said that they feel a loyalty
to this country.
>> That's an important point. Bro, that's
to do with integration. The very thing
that they're accusing Muslims of not
doing. That's an important point. Do you
know Do you know what, though? Um,
having said that, uh,
I I would say one thing. Say the one
thing, Jab.
>> I will say one thing. When they were
discussing this matter, Mhm. I was
trying to I'll be honest, I feel like
Piers Morgan came across way more
coherent than, uh, Tucker Carlson.
Tucker Carlson is American, so he's No,
but yeah, yeah, he was
>> Fox No, no, no, but he
>> You know what I mean? He is less than
that, in the sense that Piers Morgan was
clearly more intelligent in this in
exchange, all right? He just knew the
facts a lot more. He knew London,
obviously, a lot more. He's London
himself. He knew the history of World
War II a lot more. Tucker Carlson didn't
know how and why Britain got involved in
World War II, unless he was playing
dumb, which, to be honest with you, is a
disappointment for someone of his
caliber, cuz he's meant to be one of
the, you know, the conservative
top-notch guys.
>> Mhm. Um, it's a disappointment that he
doesn't know how World War started. If I
asked my 9-year-old son, he'll tell you
this is what happened. Mhm. Um,
So, the the there is a ignorance,
frankly, is an American ignorance, uh,
even at the highest levels of what's
going on in in Europe, um, and what's
some of these basic historical
geographic facts outside of their own,
uh, kind of country. So, that's
something they really need to look at if
they want to comment on these things.
But one thing that I found more
incoherent from both people, from both
Piers and Tucker Carlson near the end of
the of the podcast or whatever you want
to call that,
was their stance on homosexuality, okay?
I want you to just, um, put on what they
said, some of the things, some of the
clips they said, and then we want to
respond to that in kind. What's wrong
with homosexuality?
Well, if you encourage it and the rate
goes up, people have fewer kids. I don't
know. You Did you do biology?
>> Well, no. So, just to be clear,
>> The most gay people So, I can tell we
were both born in the 1960s, cuz we
totally agree on the underlying human
right, which is the core human right,
which is the right to conscience and
self-expression.
And both of us are on exactly the same
page. We're So, this is This is my issue
with this matter, right? You see Tucker
Carlson making an argument against
secular people. He's saying that I have
more in common with Pakistani people,
Pakistani Muslims, he's talking about,
religious Pakistanis, Pakistanis or
Bangladeshis or whatever it may be,
than I do with secular,
uh, liberals or secular white white
secular people.
Yet, he's espousing, essentially, a
secular position.
Okay, look. Both of these men claim to
be Christian, okay? Mhm.
Yet,
when they're talking about how a a
society should run, they are not
invoking Christianity once. At one
point, Piers Morgan asked Tucker Carlson
once,
uh, why why is homosexuality wrong?
You're a Christian. The correct answer
is because the Bible says so. Because
God says so.
>> morality.
>> Yeah, that's it. That But you, for some
reason, didn't mention that. And in
fact, near the end, when you were
talking about the ideas of criminalizing
homosexuality, etc., you agreed with the
idea of self-expression. Like So,
what actually makes you different,
Tucker Carlson, from
the secular liberals that you think that
you oppose? With all due respect, you
are actually one of them. You're just a
different kind. You are a secular
liberal, but it's not a liberal with a
big L, it's just a liberal with a small
L, a classical liberal.
>> And And this is This is sad to see
because apparently Christianity is
supposed to be replacing Islam.
Apparently, we're the ones that are
shunting Christianity, making it feel
making it less relevant.
>> is meant to be replacing Christianity.
No, according to them, Christianity is
supposed to be replacing Islam. That's
why they You've got this nationalistic
revival. Oh, they want that to be the
case.
>> Yeah, yeah, kicking the migrants out
because they've taken our Christian
values away. We want to revive
Christianity in this country as it once
was, they claim.
>> values are in the Bible, aren't they?
>> No, but but look, you've got Candace
Owens who does speak about the Bible,
does talk about Christianity very
brazenly and very unapologetically. She
was asked this question, in fact.
I think it was by Piers Morgan or one of
these other guys, and she said it very
clearly. No, it wasn't Piers Morgan, it
was the
one of these Don Don Lemon. Sure, sure.
From one of these American chat shows.
And she goes, "Yeah, I believe it's a
sin." And he goes, "Oh, you believe I'm
committing a sin?"
>> No, I think Carlson will tell you he
thinks it's a sin. No, but why didn't he
mention The your point was, why didn't
he invoke the very source that answers
that Yeah,
exactly. Exactly.
>> And that's the same Like he's shy to to
to make mention his religion. He's
clearly a Christian, okay? And And
ironically, Piers Morgan is a Catholic
Christian as well. So, it's a Christian
speaking to a Christian.
>> yeah. And both of them are just like
rejecting Christian teachings for 2,000
years. Not just the Bible, by the way,
the councils and the Bible and the Pope
and the rulings and all of this kind of
stuff. Like you're you're rejecting all
of that that in favor, actually, of the
very thing that Tucker Carlson was
suggesting or he thinks that he's
against, which he's actually not
against. People have to understand the
difference, and this is why, once again,
with all due respect, I know Tucker
Carlson's been really good with the
Palestine issue. And he's been really
good with the Muslims, and I'm not
trying to alienate him or disrespect
him. But with all due respect, this is a
matter of
academic ineptitude, actually. That just
like when you were talking about
the war and how you didn't know how it
started, etc., you also don't understand
where an ideology starts and where it
ends. Because what is secularism? It's a
division of church and state, right?
Secularism is where you're not using
You are not using religion, okay? In to
govern states and stuff like that,
right? Which by the way, I just I don't
want to go into too much of a tangent,
but actually it actually contradicts
principles of democracy.
Because secularism
and democracy can sometimes conflict.
Let's say, for example, the majority of
a society want to have abortion banned
for religious reasons, right? For the
sake of argument. Then then you have a
conflict between a democratic impetus
and a secular one, okay? So,
the assumption usually is that Western
values all come together and coalesce
and harmonize in a manner that don't
contradict, and they're contradistinct
all the time, which is actually false. I
mean, sometimes you can have liberalism
which contradicts secularism and
secularism which can contradicts
democracy, etc. So, that's one point.
But the point I'm making to Carlson is
that he is essentially espousing a
secular position, okay? And he he's
against these liberals that he keeps
talking about, but he's a liberal
himself in the sense that he believes
that society should be run in a socially
liberal way, the kind of society that
J.S. Mill and others would have
envisaged. This is called liberalism,
classical liberalism, and that's
different from the liberalism of the
left-wing people which he opposes. So,
really, he's not too dissimilar from
those who he claims to oppose. Mhm.
It's It's kind of like a faux
opposition. Um If you want to take a
>> Faux show. Yeah, for sure. Yeah, if you
want to take a real revolutionary
stance, just be honest about Say this
This is what you should say. Come out
and say, "Look, I'm a Christian, you're
a Christian.
I don't accept anything but Christianity
to arbitrate arbitrate our matters in in
morality because morality comes from
God, and morality is an objective thing.
I believe homosexuality is wrong because
the Bible says it, okay? And because for
Christian history, 2,000 years, everyone
agrees. And that it's not not to do with
this, that, and the other. If If that
goes against the American Constitution,
if it goes against freedom of speech and
expression, if it goes against
conservative neoconservative Whatever it
goes against, it doesn't matter because
Jesus said it or whatever, and that he's
inspired by God or in your case, he was
God. This section on homosexuality and
the homos,
I don't know why I looked at you when I
said it. I didn't mean to look at you.
>> [laughter]
[clears throat]
[snorts]
>> So, there was a discussion about the gay
gene, yeah? About being born gay. Nature
discussed this in their journal in 2015
saying there is no such thing as the gay
gene. And then he kept asking Tucker
Carlson, "What is the issue with
homosexuality? Like what's
What's What's the What's the problem
with homosexuality?"
There's so many studies that have been
done on it. One that talks about
children that come from homosexual
households,
they actually have psychological issues.
And this was mentioned in 2022 by
Segalit Zohar in his study. Then Rob
Stephenson in 2016, in his study, he
says that children that come from
same-sex
households, they have a higher rate of
ADHD. Then [snorts] again, these
children that come from those families
have developmental issues. 2015, Richard
Fitzgibbons mentioned it. In fact, 83%
of syphilis cases in the United States
were of homosexuals. It wouldn't explain
you, though, would Oh,
but it It It took you a good 2 minutes
[laughter] to formulate that, and that's
what you came up with. No, no, no, you
need 2 more minutes. So, 2014, the CDC
mentioned that.
>> [snorts]
>> And then, like I mentioned, there is no
gay gene. But Well, look, I mean, that's
really, really good. Look,
but but let me say this, right?
In And I've mentioned this many times,
I'll mention it again. In Western
ethics, there are two major
descriptive schools of thought, which
are consequentialist and Kantian, or you
call them deontological ethics, yeah?
What you are basically making are a
series of consequentialist arguments,
okay? So, in other words, you're saying
that if you have homosexuality in a
society that
what you'll get is you'll get more
syphilis, you'll get more sexually
transmitted diseases.
>> kept pressing him on this and saying,
"What is the issue with it?" And that's
a stronger argument than what Tucker
Carlson came up with, "Oh, you have less
birth rates and stuff." That's only one
argument, okay? You have to combine the
consequences. And once again, it shows a
lack of criticality from Tucker Carlson
to the point where, with respect, it
actually
surprises me that he's reached that
level
in conservative circles. Because if
that's If you can't think about If you
want to make a consequentialist
argument, if you can't think about that
level of things,
then it surprises me that you you are
the thought leader for your for your
people. I mean, if you're Fox host or if
you're GB News host, you thrive on
outrage. And that's You don't thrive
over a high IQ. It's It's who can make
the most
outlandish, outrageous statements, and
that's how these people get propped up.
Look at Tommy Robinson, the amount of
things that this guy has done, the
amount of times he's been arrested, the
amount of times his own group There's
been groomers to come out of his own
group and child abusers. It's
ridiculous.
Under his own watch, the amount of
nonsense he said that is unpatriotic,
that is downright racist, but yet his
people still continue to back him.
>> less intelligent, way less, you know,
sophisticated than this. But anyway,
look, I mean, no problem. I think Piers
Morgan
came across well here. Except, you know,
I mean, obviously, that last segment
about the LGBT and stuff like that. It's
just so incommensurate with with
Christianity and stuff. They have to
explain that. Someone has to push them
and say to them, "Explain your You are
Christians, yeah? So, why do you think
it's okay to Tucker Carlson should have
turned around and said, 'You are a
Christian, okay? It's sacrilegious and
it's blasphemous for you to believe in
this.'" Okay, why is that conversation
not being had? I don't know.
But, you know, we have to give them
credit. Go back to where we started. We
have to start We end off by giving them
credit for the way they
speak about the Muslim community. I
think it's very respectful. And we
appreciate that, to be honest. And And
to be honest, I think Piers Morgan, for
all it's worth, for what it's worth, I
think he's not a racist, you know? I
think he he has kind of People that are
born in London, people that are mixing
It's true that when you go Brick Lane
and Portobello and stuff, it's
difficult.
With anybody who's interacted with
Muslims, who actually with blacks, who
actually with with people from different
from Asia, from whatever it may be,
it's difficult to hate these people. And
I think, to be fair, Piers Morgan is not
a racist, and he's not a hate He doesn't
hate the Muslim community. He just had
some very, very bad takes on the
genocide. We hope that he amends his
ways, and we hope Tucker Carlson also
amends his ways as well, and continues
his good work at the same time. And yes,
we are ready to
>> [clears throat]
>> more clearer stance on homosexuality.
Well, yeah. I mean, and why not have a
conversation with Muslims as well? We
can show you how to live your life the
way the prophets uh
the way the prophets recommended,
including Jesus Christ. But that's
something for another day.
Was salaam alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. Your brothers and sisters in
Islam net from Norway are establishing a
masjid, a dawah center.
This center, this masjid, this
educational institution will act like a
beacon of light calling the Muslims in
Norway back to the essence of Islam. So,
give generously and Allah Azza wa Jal
will give you even more.